[Music]  developing this morning metro police are  investigating the first homicide of the  year  in their jurisdiction it happened last  night at an apartment on  dunsbach way that's near lake mead in  hollywood officers responded to calls  about gunshots  heard during a party at the apartment  when they arrived they found a black man  dead with a gunshot wound  in the driveway police have limited  information on potential suspects  because  just many of the people at the party ran  away before police arrived  they're urging anyone with any  information on this shooting to call  crime stoppers you can see that number  on your screen and you can remain  anonymous  there's also reward money available